now to the latest on the pandemic and
the massive surge of the omicron variant
the cdc reports that an average of about
one in four covet tests is coming back
positive and that is a huge increase all
50 states are reporting a high level of
community transmission missouri has one
of the lowest vaccination rates in the
country and the kova situation is dire
carter evans is in kansas city which is
averaging more than 3 400 new cases
every day and hospitals are swamped with
patients
good morning pam i'm going to open your
eyes
at st luke's hospital dr andrew
schlachter and his colleagues are
treating covid patients everywhere they
can you're in our neurosciences icu
if you have someone who comes in with a
neurological issue right now you don't
have any beds where do they go
right now we try and take care of
patients in any variety of places that
we can
just since december the number of
infected patients here nearly tripled
out of 286 covid patients at this
hospital
only 15 are vaccinated are you coughing
pamela maples avoided the vaccine
because she thought it was more
dangerous than covet were you concerned
about covid before when she tested
positive last month she was in the
hospital eight days later i had no clue
it would be like this what did you think
it might be oh like it's a flu
some regular old flu
and that's what everybody
kept telling me it's a story nurse
kristen sawlers hears too often there's
a lot of anger about the community not
wanting to take care of themselves and
asking for us to pick up that slack when
they become critically ill and other
days it's really profound sadness
because
we have the saddest stories you've ever
heard in your life and after weeks in
the hospital pamela maples is now
begging others to get the shot
take the vaccine
very very important
now pam's ex-husband was also in the
hospital here being treated for covid
but he died last week and after
everything this family has been through
pam says there are still some close
friends and family members that will not
get the vaccine
gail
i don't know what more people need to
see but thank you very much carter we
have to just keep telling this story
thanks a lot